[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy who's his own
biggest fan like my man OB the finale of
Lucky season 2 is right around the
corner and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down all the
remaining shots giving our theories on
them and talking about the potential
Easter eggs that might be coming up
heavy spoilers ahead and we have some
leaked artwork for the promotion of the
series which could potentially spoil
what they do with Loki if it's real then
you might want to avoid it like your
brothers getting a snake that's a Thor
and Loki and mobus kid joke in one and
without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
trailer Loki how much do you know let's
assume I don't know much but I'm a fast
learner and I'm a god well let's start
at the beginning here we
go now I think that this scene happens
when Loki and Sylvia are at the automat
during episode 4 that would stop him
from running into himself and creating
further branches out from this point now
before diving into this I think we have
to talk about the way that time travel's
been changed in the show so I can give
you a clearer idea of what's going on
firstly it was operating off the
bootstrap Paradox which meant that
everything had a cause and effect if
you've been watching bodies on Netflix
and you know that it works in the same
way but lots of time travel shows use
the same device dark for example that's
another great one check out triangle the
movie CU that's that that's brilliant as
well now boil down to its simplest terms
though the theory states that a
scientist one day gets a knock at the
door and they open it to discover a buck
that's being left on the ground reading
through it this tells them how to build
a time machine which they then make and
travel into the past at this point they
then leave themselves the book and the
cycle then continues out from this
moment this is sort of a chicken and egg
situation in which there's not really a
start or an end it's just one big loop
all happening across time now this is
something that we also saw with Victor
timely and I think that because of this
he in some ways creates he who remains
either way the entire show has been
working in a loop but Loy managed to
break this during episode 5 he was able
to travel back in time and interact with
things and alter them from the way that
they happened in the past now Loki is
still in the exact same position he
doesn't bump into himself so he's kind
of taking over his Consciousness in his
past life if that makes sense if you've
seen the butterfly effect it sort of
works in the same way with Ashton
Kutcher going back to his Consciousness
in the past and then doing things
differently now as we know with the way
the time travel works in the MCU if you
change things it creates a branch in
reality therefore Loki going back to the
moment at the end of episode 4
everything from this point will create a
branch in time that's important to bear
in mind when you watch this next clip
which I think shows he's repeating
certain moments here we go listen to me
carefully hit the green button it can be
a little sticky here we see him
instructing Victor timely and later on
we see a different angle of him getting
turned to spaghetti I believe that he's
going to keep traveling back to this
moment and in the end he'll realize he
has to be the one to do it thus he goes
out onto the bridge which is a shot we
get in the trailer showing that he has
to be the one who saves it focus on that
who there now again going to the whole
branch and time thing technically these
are all different realities however what
I think will happen is that they'll go
down a route in which the attempt
actually works and this will leave that
as being the sacred timeline the other
branches could then be pruned leaving
just the one in which they sa the TVA
think about how it worked in Infinity
War an endgame you know Dr strange saw
all those different timelines but in the
end they went down the one that caused
them to come out on top all those other
timelines they were still likely out
there but you know that one it just got
them to the end now in the teaser we
also see a green strand effect heading
out to Loki though this didn't happen in
the episode I think it's in the trailer
to give us a little clue that takes us
to the leak Loki image that showed
similar green strands all being held by
him I believe that Loki will end up as
the ruler of all time and that after he
heads to the bridge he'll be be taken
somewhere else potentially in fixing the
loom he also gains control of it and now
becomes the person who takes over he who
remains and we've seen in the other
trailers how raavana can be seen down in
the void clearly coming face to face
with the Beast of life I actually think
that the way things are going to work is
that we're going to get these two
stories balanced alongside each other I
think when we get the scene where Loki
walks along the bridge that at this
point he'll say things and will hear
this there's something you have to see I
think Miss minut will reveal to him that
he's actually at the end of time and
that raana will discover this version
somewhere in the void I believe that
she'll Escape it like how Loki and selie
did but whereas they saw he who remains
she'll see Loki that ties in in the
agent of ascar comic book which this
Series has taken a lot of inspiration
from in that ly was sick of basically
being a loser that only succeeded in
bringing people together to stop him
this is something that they touched upon
in season one but the similarities go
far beyond that agent of Asgard Loki
managed to make it to the end of time
but rather than seeing he who remains he
met his other self he'd been the one
that had been controlling it all and I
think that this will be where they take
the show that leaked artwork it shows
him holding all the strands and if
that's real then it makes sense they'd
head that way a huge shout out to Josh
from den of nerds who actually had a
really good theory on this whole thing
he brought up how fargi is now in
control of Marvel Comics 2 and that he's
been slutting in ideas for them that'll
pay off in the MCU Josh thinks that ly
may be Avenger Prime who exists at the
end of time but I'm not a rapper he's
been rounding up Avengers and bringing
them together much like how Loki does in
the latest Cent I actually think that ly
might end up being at the end of time
and here he could become Avengers Prime
who collects Avengers in time to fight K
I'm not didn't mean to make that rhyme
but it did Rhyme now with the word rhyme
as well now from what I've heard Secret
Wars is going to be a big multiversal
event with lots of characters pulled
from across time and different universes
this includes the fox X-men Spider-Man
franchises fantastic for MCU and so on
we have heard there's been talks to
bring scarjo and RDJ back and having
this would also make a lot of sense now
on top of this there's also the fact
that Loki can now time slip as well Time
Keeps On Slipping Into the Future and he
could potentially travel to whatever
Point he'd like to recruit whatever
members he wants to and then bring them
into this War I think that would make a
ton of sense and it would allow them to
basically redeem Loki into being this
hero leading the charge against Kang I
also even think that Loki might have
been the one who was in charge of he who
remains in the first place with him
believing that he ruled it all he was
the one that had the script but in order
to have that someone had to write it now
in terms of where the show could be
going in the future I really hope that
Mobius gets returned to his family what
seems likely though is that Loki's
recruiting these agents here so that
they can all be used as part of the TVA
they've now all had their memories wiped
and thus the cycle may be able to start
again soon who knows Loki might not even
save the T Eva and its destruction could
be a necessary part of this entire cycle
this then has to come out and be built
up again From the Ashes and it'll all
start aresh either way there's lots of
directions they can take things but I
think the next episode we'll see the
scene in which Loki instructs Victor
early on failing to do the job he'll
guard instead and it's at this point
that it'll all come together the finale
rumor to be 56 minutes long and th they
have lots of things that they have to
cover the way the Variety article lay
things out it looks like Kang's going to
be a major threat in the end which will
of course lead into things further down
the line now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts was spitballing a lot here
coming coming out a lots of theories but
at the end of the day you know you guys
should have some input too also please
drop a like on the video and if you want
to support the channel as a member of
the spoiler Society then please click
the join button you'll get early access
to videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out if you want
to get some heavy spoilers merch we've
also got our t-shirt line located below
the video and right now we're selling
playing a l in spy t-shirt we also got
our Theory time one you know all all the
crap we've made so far H so yeah
definitely head over there and if you
want to get one of them to show off to
your friends you don't have any friends
do you now if you want something else to
watch we've got a video on screen right
now uh breaking down the Loki episode 5
what happened in that cheese but thanks
for sticking with me up until this point
I love you I've been up since 3:00 a.m.
it's now uh it's now six we've done so
many breakdowns but uh yeah I'll see you
next time and you take care yourself